good evening and welcome to Tucker
Carl's tonight we're going to start with
a quiz what do you have when you find it
Sam bankman freed Janet Yellen and
president zielinski of Ukraine all
together in one room
a Federal grand jury proceeding that
would be a good guess Sam bankman freed
seems to have committed the biggest
financial fraud in history as the chair
of the Federal Reserve Janet
yellenbear's direct responsibility for
the destruction of the entire U.S
economy president zielinski meanwhile
sits atop a money laundering scheme so
Brazen that Democrats won't even allow
it to be audited
so yes these are three people who could
badly use a federal investigation but
they're not getting one instead they're
being celebrated held up as uniquely
Fascinating People by the New York Times
in case you missed it today was the
annual deal book Summit that's a
money-making event the newspaper
advertises as a symposium with quote Top
Business Leaders tickets went for 2500
bucks a piece Sam bankman free Janet
Yellen and Vladimir zielinski were all
there apparently in their capacity as
top Business Leaders
thank you so very much exclaimed the
moderator Andrew Ross Sorkin when Sam
bankman freed finished speaking thank
you Sam bankman freed everybody and with
that the audience applauded heartily New
York Times readers were clearly
impressed by the Democratic Mega donor
Sam bankman freed who also happens to be
one of the most prolific thieves of all
time but whatever he seemed like a nice
kid
it was a pretty amazing display but
what's most interesting about an event
like this is not what it tells us about
the guests at some point history will
render its judgment about them but what
it tells us about the people who invited
the guests
if it's okay to treat Sam bankman free
like just another naughty celebrity Sam
Beckman freed everybody applause
applause applause
if you can do that then who's off limits
who's Beyond The Pale
well as it happens the New York Times
has spent the last few days telling us
delivering yet another hyperventilating
lecture about who we're allowed to
associate with and who we must avoid at
all costs and it really depends on
political loyalty some people the New
York Times has explained have views that
are so reprehensible these people are
physically off limits you cannot be in
the same room with people like that you
can't talk to them you can't ask them
questions their opinions are like
smallpox communicable and deadly
these are the thought criminals and
thought crimes are the only crimes that
matter other crimes not such a big deal
murder and rape and carjacking
[Music]
as the New York Times has often told us
people who do those things are the
victims of your racism so they deserve
compassion so by the way do good
liberals who stray Outside the Lines
good liberals can always be forgiven
even when the things they've done are
objectively very very bad like tanking
the US economy or stealing billions from
investors and using it to buy Bahamian
real estate or bringing the entire world
to the brink of nuclear war and getting
rich while you do it
liberals can still do these things and
you can still heartily applaud them
because in the end you know their hearts
are in the right place they believe the
right things
so with that in mind it probably is not
a surprise that no one at the New York
Times bothered to ask zelinsky today
where exactly all the money has gone
no one demanded an accounting of the
billions of your tax dollars it seems to
have disappeared into the pockets of
Ukrainian oligarchs in track suits
because asking would have been rude he
was our guest
so instead the New York Times gave
solensky an opportunity to demand much
more of your money which of course he
promptly took here's part of it
on November 15th the Biden
Administration submitted a new Aid
request of 37.7 billion dollars which if
passed would bring the total amount that
the U.S has provided in in in assistance
to 105.5 billion dollars we're going to
be speaking with former vice president
Mike Pence a little bit later and there
has been a sentiment among Republicans
who now control the house in the United
States from Kevin McCarthy who said
there should not be a blank check what
do you tell them
we are absolutely open
and we are thankful for the assistance
it's not quite correct to speak about
100 million billion as a value of the
war for the United States the value is
the lives of people if Ukraine does not
stand through this war the war will
spread into other territories and maybe
even to other continents so our people
is the biggest value tell me how much
our people cost I don't know
[Laughter]
okay
so support me or Putin's gonna invade
Atlanta and by the way you have no
choice because if you object to sending
billions more to the very people who
gave a no-show job to Hunter Biden
you're a bad person
you don't care about Ukrainian lives
you're a moral mod
now moral This Crew does not typically
work because nobody was self-respect
would stand for it what settle down son
get the Germans to pay for it it's their
continent that's what a normal person
would say someone who had self-respect
unfortunately for the rest of us
Congressman Michael McCall of Texas has
no self-respect so he folded immediately
and that matters because McCall is the
top Republican on the house Foreign
Affairs committee so just in case that
you imagined that throwing out Nancy
Pelosi and electing a republican
Congress a huge Victory would mean that
somebody would push back against Joe
Biden's lunatic and completely
anti-American foreign policy priorities
oh you were mistaken
because Michael McCall just informed us
that because we're good people and so
was zielinski we're going to be sending
Mr zlinski and his Pals in track suits
billions more of your money watch
and I want to pick up where Colonel
Milburn left off he believes that there
should be longer range weapons sent to
Ukraine would you approve of that 100
he's absolutely correct I mean I my
criticism of this Administration was
before The Invasion we wouldn't put
weapons in and since the invasion we've
slow walked this process we are going to
provide more oversight transparency and
accountability we're not going to write
a blank check does that diminish our
will to help the Ukraine people fight no
but we're going to do it in a
responsible way and I think it's very
important the American people understand
what's at stake here
so the U.S military not Ukraine's
military our military the one that's
supposed to protect our country is
running out of equipment and Manpower
but just so we're all clear about what
Michael McCall's priorities are we're
sending Advanced weapon systems yet more
of them to Ukraine and that's in
addition what we've already sent which
is bigger than the entire Russian
military budget so if that's not
insulting enough and of course the point
of this is to insult you and to degrade
you and to make you fully aware that
your country's Interest come will last
because you come last on the list of
priorities they're going farther than
that we've also decided to pay Ukraine's
energy bills now it's kind of odd that
we're doing that at a time when we have
our first real energy crisis since the
mid-1970s a manufactured crisis but a
crisis nevertheless a crisis that is
causing Americans to freeze in their
homes because they can't afford heating
oil that means it's a perfect time to
send energy
to our friends in Ukraine and the whole
region here's Tony blinken
I announced the United States will
commit over 53 million dollars to send
equipment to help stabilize Ukraine's
energy grid and keep Ukraine's power and
electricity running
we've also submitted a request to
Congress for 1.1 billion dollars to
secure Ukraine and moldova's energy
sector and restore their energy Supply
so why is this continuing when of course
Joe Biden could call zielinski who
effectively works for him I mean a close
family connections there of course his
son worked in Ukraine could cause lensky
and say you know no Moss get the money
from Europe or let's wrap this thing up
people are dying the rebuilding costs of
this country are beyond what we can pay
this is really a dead end let's come to
a settlement and of course that could
happen in about a week if they wanted it
to but they don't want that they want
them more to keep going why is that oh
because everyone's getting rich
and so the one thing you're not allowed
to say is that hey maybe we should stop
this war because of course the cash
spigot would stop flowing and that's why
at the deal book Summit
the top business leader zelenski in fact
is really a top business leader if you
want to be honest about it when after
Elon Musk because Elon Musk suggested
maybe we should get a peace deal here he
is
it seems that Elon began to change his
opinion and we began to hear all kinds
of appeals I don't know if somebody is
making a influence on him or he is
making those choices himself I always
say very uh openly if you want to
understand what Russia has done here
come to Ukraine and you will see this
with your own eyes without any extra
words and after that you will tell us
how to end this war who started it and
when we can end it
oh all perfectly reasonable can't have
peace send more billions
so what's interesting is that this last
few days has been like the few days
before that there's been a lot of moral
outrage in Washington about bad ideas
and of course some ideas are bad on both
sides for sure
but ideas aren't criminal actions are
criminal and as always the real
criminals are getting away with it and
getting richer in the process subscribe
to the Fox News YouTube channel to catch
our nightly opens stories that are
changing the world and changing your
life from Tucker Carlson tonight